could storm eunice bring a rare but
severe weather phenomena the sting jet
according to forecasters there are signs
the low pressure system may have all the
ingredients and it could mean some areas
of southern britain suffer extreme
hurricane force winds well in excess of
100 miles an hour so what is a sting jet
well it gets its name from a curl of
cloud that looks a bit like a scorpion's
tail it starts a couple of miles above
the ground cold air in the upper
atmosphere gets funneled towards the
center of the storm system and because
cold air is dense it begins to sink
rapidly as rain and snow falls into it
and then evaporates the air gets colder
causing the jet to plunge even faster by
the time it hits the ground it can
generate stronger gusts than the rest of
the storm but only in a small area and
perhaps just 30 miles across
it doesn't last long typically it's all
over in just three to four hours
sting jets were first identified by
meteorologists as recently as 2004 but
looking back they now think a sting jet
was at the heart of the great storm of
1987 that caused utter devastation
across the south of the uk and there
have been many sting jets since
according to the royal meteorological
society they were a feature of 32 of the
100 most intense storms between 1993 and
2013 causing widespread flooding and
damage they are difficult to forecast
with precision though because they're
only a small part of a much bigger storm
but even if eunice spares us a sting jet
the rapidly deepening area of low
pressure will bring damaging winds on
friday across large parts of the uk